alarmierende infektionszahlen das rkw
ruft die politik zum handeln auf und
verzeichnet gleichzeitig einen neuen
rekord mieten deckel gekippt das
bundesverfassungsgericht erklärt berlins
mietobergrenzen für nichtig und bittere
niederlage borussia dortmund scheiterte
im champions league viertelfinale an
mensch ist das
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen norbert lehmann ist auch
dabei für den sport ein bekannter von
mir
wir müssen die dritte welle brechen und
zwar schnell
so der eindringliche appell des
robert-koch-instituts heute gerichtet
vor allem an die politik es brauche
erneut deutliche kontakt beschränkungen
der gesundheitsminister fordert die
länder auf nicht auf die bundes
notbremse zu warten jeder tag zähle die
aktuellen zahlen des rk ii dazu 29 1426
neuinfektionen die sieben tage incidents
liegt jetzt über 160 das bringt die
intensivstationen zum teil an ihre
grenzen
die zahl der belegten betten mit corona
patienten und weiteren kranken stieg mit
schwankungen in den vergangenen wochen
auf rund 21.000 höchststand in der
pandemie thomas reichert berichtet die
infektionszahlen steigen wie
vorhergesagt wie befürchtet nun was
daraus folgt dass es seit wochen
umstritten
der gesundheitsminister drängt auf neue
harte einschnitte abzuwarten bis das
bundesweit in notbremsen gesetz in kraft
sei reiche nicht die zeit drängt und
bereits jetzt haben alle auch die
möglichkeit schon zu handeln man muss
nicht auf dieses bundesgesetz wachten
impfen und testen alleine reicht nicht
und die dritte welle zu brechen
dafür braucht es entschiedenes handeln
und so schwer das ist weitere
einschränkungen
ärzte berichten von einer dramatischen
lage allein im letzten monat sei die
zahl der intensivpatienten bundesweit um
2.000 gestiegen krankenhäuser com an
ihre grenzen müssen patienten schon in
andere bundesländer verlegen
da beginnen die ersten strategischen
prozent zulegen
in andere bereiche damit wir überhaupt
in der lage sind diese diesen strom der
patienten zu bewältigen und wir laufen
im moment sehen denn auf es in spitzen
belasten die wir zu sagen um die aus den
daten um dem entgegenzuwirken müssten
kontakte drastisch eingeschränkt werden
auch durch die umstrittene
ausgangssperre nachts es geht darum
zusammenkünfte innenräumen zu vermeiden
es gibt durchaus auch studien aus
anderen ländern dass es ein wirksames
mittel ist um kontakte einzuschränken
dass das geplante den notbremsen gesetz
schulschließungen erst ab einer inzidenz
von über 200 vorsieht kritisieren sparen
wie auch wieder wenn wir jetzt die
inzidenz handy weiter steigen und die
inzidenz nicht runtergebracht werden
dann werden natürlich auch die anzahl
der infektionen in den schulen steigen
aus meiner sicht ist die 200er incidents
grenze zu hoch weil man dann sehr viele
infektionen haben wird morgen kommt das
notbremsen gesetz in den bundestag und
könnte ende nächster woche in kraft
treten
bis dahin wird um änderungen gerungen
und die inzidenz wird wohl weiter nach
oben gehen geimpft wurden gestern in
deutschland übrigens so viele menschen
wie noch nie fast 700 39.000 die
situation auf den intensivstationen und
die verantwortung der politik ist thema
bei zdf heute live um 19 uhr 30 zu sehen
in unserer app und sie können auch
mitreden per mail oder über die sozialen
medien und jetzt zu einer entscheidung
mit enormen folgen vor allem für weit
mehr als eine million mieterinnen und
mieter der sogenannte berliner mieten
decke ist verfassungswidrig sagt das
bundesverfassungsgericht eine schwere
niederlage für den senat der hatte per
gesetz mieten eingefroren und
obergrenzen festgelegt doch das alles
hätte es nicht geben dürfen so die
richter den schaden haben die mieter
einige müssen jetzt wohl sogar nach
zahlen christoph schneider von vielen
gefordert aber auch heftig umstritten
war von anfang an der berliner mieten
deckel ende februar 2020 traten
kraft uns sollte für gut 1,5 millionen
wohnungen in der hauptstadt für fünf
jahre gelten
doch dieses gesetz ist verfassungswidrig
denn der bund hat schon 2015 eine
allgemeine mietpreis bremse eingeführt
so das bundesverfassungsgericht
der bund hat mit der mietpreis bremse
seine gesetzgebungskompetenz
abschließend wahrgenommen
dadurch kann eine sperrwirkung 1 das
heißt es gibt keinen raum für eigene
landesgesetzliche regelungen so die
richterinnen und richter in karlsruhe
denn der bundesgesetzgeber hat in den
vorschriften des bürgerlichen
gesetzbuchs das mietpreis recht
umfassend ausführlich und auch
abschließend geregelt
für die spd eine herbe niederlage
wir fordern seit langem als spd
bundestagsfraktion und als spd dass es
einen bundesweiten gesicherten
verfassungsgemäßen mieten stopp gibt um
angespannte wohnungsmärkte zu entlasten
entlastungen sie in die kläger dagegen
nicht durch eine mieten deckelung
sondern mehr neuer wohnraum müsse her
wir werden das problem angespannter
wohnungsmärkte in deutschland nur dann
lösen wenn wir mehr investitionen in
wohnraum haben wenn mehr gebaut wird
wenn auch wohnraum aufgewertet wird und
der berliner mieten deckel war eine
investitionsbremse die klare botschaft
aus karlsruhe
berlins alleingang ist kassiert sollten
andere länder mieten deckel überlegt
haben sind die jetzt vom tisch
schon als der mieten deckel in kraft
trat hat die berliner senatsverwaltung
geraten das gesparte geld
vorsichtshalber zurück zu legen wer das
nicht wollte oder konnte hat jetzt
möglicherweise ein problem
vermieter und das sind in berlin oft
große immobiliengesellschaften können
nämlich mietzahlungen nachfordern
romanesco war
fünf jahre lang die mieten einfrieren
der mieten deckel war das prestige
projekt des rot rot grünen senats die
gerichtsentscheidung eine bittere
niederlage ist ein sehr schwerer tag für
den senat und auch die mieterinnen und
mieter von berlin das karlsruher so
deutlich entscheidet ist auch für uns
überraschend
vor allem bei mietervereinen sorgte der
deckel für einen ansturm betroffene
meldeten sich um überhöhte mieten zu
senken oder neuverträge zu überprüfen
jetzt drohen nachzahlungen die
mieterlobby enttäuscht wir appellieren
an die vermieter hier sozusagen
großzügig mit ratenzahlungen
gegebenenfalls auch weiteres
missgeschick zu vermeiden aber wir
werden natürlich auch prüfen ob die
vereinbarung überhaupt wirksam sind auch
vermieterverbände rechnet mit
nachzahlungen kündigungen müsse aber
niemand fürchten hier begrüßt man die
richtungsweisende entscheidung berlins
experimente aber auch in anderen
bundesländern keine chance das bedeutet
dass man wieder planungssicherheit hat
und wir hoffen dass es wieder mehr
mietwohnungen auf dem wohnungsmarkt
geben wird dass es gut für die mieter
die eine mietwohnung suchen und es ist
natürlich auch gut für private vermieter
die ihre wohnung zur miete anbieten
wollen in den vergangenen jahren waren
die mietpreise in der hauptstadt stark
gestiegen wenn manch berliner sind mit
dem beschluss hoffnungen geplatzt
ich hätte mir auch gewünscht natürlich
dass man diese hohen extrem hohen mieten
bisschen im griff so dürfte die debatte
mit der heutigen entscheidung wohl nicht
enden im gegenteil nicht nur im berliner
wahlkampf könnte das mieten thema weiter
an bedeutung gewinnen sondern auch im
bund
im machtkampf um die kanzlerkandidatur
haben sich heute zwei
cdu-ministerpräsidenten zu wort gemeldet
reiner haseloff aus sachsen anhalt ist
indirekt von parteichef laschet als
kanzlerkandidat abgerückt dem spiegel
sagte haseloff es gehe nicht um
persönliche sympathie vertrauen oder
charaktereigenschaften sondern um die
harte machtfrage und die besten chancen
und damit um popularitätswerte in
umfragen liegt derzeit markus söder form
schleswig holsteins regierungschef
daniel günther
forderte söder dagegen zum rückzug auf
nach 20 jahren einsatz will auch die
bundeswehr afghanistan verlassen und
zwar bis mitte august das hat
verteidigungsministerin kramp
karrenbauer den bundestags fraktionen
mitgeteilt
auslöser waren die usa gestern hatte der
präsident angekündigt seine truppen bis
zum 11 september abzuziehen
in kabul ist us-außenminister blinken zu
einem unangekündigten besuch
eingetroffen
dem afghanischen präsidenten gar nie
versicherte er dass die usa das land
auch weiterhin unterstützen werden
die korona krise reisst ein tiefes loch
in den staatshaushalt ein vorschlag
führender wirtschaftsinstitute das
rentenalter auf 69 jahre heraufzusetzen
für dieses jahr haben die
wissenschaftler ihre wachstumsprognose
deutlich gesenkt von 4,7 auf 3,7 prozent
die dritte welle treffe die wirtschaft
härter als noch im herbst angenommen
wirtschaftlich angeschlagen ist auch die
türkei dazu kommen explodierende
infektionszahlen in dem land mit 83
millionen einwohnern wurden allein
gestern mehr als 62.000 700
neuinfektionen gemeldet so viele wie
noch nie
die regierung hat die beschränkungen
jetzt noch einmal verschärft und fährt
das öffentliche leben zum ramadan
beginnt konsequent herunter report
berichtet hitzige stimmung am mittag in
istanbul vertreter von ärzteverbänden
pflegepersonal und klinik angestellten
kritisieren die korona maßnahmen der
regierung erdogan zu wenig zu zögerlich
stoppt das sterben fordern sie die
kliniken vor allem in istanbul seien
völlig überlastet die intensivstationen
sind voll der minister sagt zu 80
prozent aber das ist der
landesdurchschnitt hier sind wir bei 100
prozent es gibt keine plätze mehr in den
kliniken
die regierung verweist auf die gut
angelaufene impfkampagne mehr als elf
millionen türkische bürger sind bereits
geimpft doch die dritte welle ist längst
voll im gang die zahlen steigen rasant
mehr als 62.000 infizierte knapp 280
tote allein gestern
ein trauriger rekord die sieben tages
incidents über 460 erst vor einem monat
hatte die regierung gegen den
ausdrücklichen rat von experten
lockerungen beschlossen
auch um die wirtschaftslage zu
verbessern in der folge gingen die
infektions kurve steil nach oben
präsident erdogan zog eine halbe
notbremse für die ersten zwei wochen des
ramadan müssen wir die shutdown
maßnahmen etwas verschärfen um die
zahlen zu senken jetzt sind restaurants
und cafés wieder geschlossen außer
lieferservice es herrscht ausgangssperre
ab 19 uhr abends und am gesamten
wochenende verschärft wird die krone
krise noch durch den starken
wirtschaftseinbruch mit 16 prozent
inflation und fast 30 prozent
arbeitslosigkeit
ein rascher wiederaufschwung ist derzeit
nicht in sicht
zurück nach deutschland zunächst die
erfreuliche nachricht aus der
kriminalstatistik wie schon seit jahren
ging auch 2020 die zahl der straftaten
wie einbrüche weiter zurück um 2,3
prozent gegenüber 2009 10
gestiegen ist allerdings die zahl von
fällen sexuellen kindesmissbrauchs und
häuslicher gewalt benthin berichtet
wegen corona sind die meisten menschen
mehr zu hause weniger gelegenheit für
diebe also bei vielen delikten sinken
die zahlen deutlich wohnungseinbrüche
zum beispiel minus 13,9 prozent die
kontakt und ausgangs beschränkungen
hatten und haben gravierende
auswirkungen auf die lebensbedingungen
der bürgerinnen und bürger in
deutschland
dies hat einfluss auf die mobilität und
führt auch zu veränderungen auch bei den
straftaten erheblich gestiegen ist die
kriminalität im internet
jüngstes beispiel das abgreifen von
corona hilfen mit gefälschten
nutzerprofilen
mehr online aktivität bedeutet auch
deutlich mehr angriffsfläche für
kriminelle die tatsache dass sich aber
in hoher geschwindigkeit vieles von
unserem leben ins netz verlagert hat
diese dynamische entwicklung ist häufig
auf kosten der sicherheit gegangen
die polizei hat im vergangenen jahr auch
mehr sexuellen missbrauch an kindern
aufgedeckt die fallzahlen stiegen um 6,8
prozent dazu die befürchtung dass viele
taten aufgrund des schattens gänzlich
unentdeckt blieben wir gehen davon aus
dass das eben nicht die gesamte weit ist
nur ein ausschnitt weil natürlich auch
die sozialkontrolle eingeschränkt war an
dem zeitraum zum beispiel weil die
kinder nicht in die schulen gehen etc
klicken sie weniger hinweise von dritten
einen positiv fährt kann horst seehofer
noch verkünden insgesamt gegen die
kriminalität in den letzten 15 jahren um
mehr als 15 prozent zurück jetzt schauen
wir nach polen seit jahren sieht die
eben kommission die unabhängigkeit der
justiz dort bedroht aktuell befeuert
durch den fall des
menschenrechtsbeauftragten adam bodner
der muss innerhalb von drei monaten sein
amt abgeben entschied heute das
verfassungsgericht bodner hat polens
nationalkonservative regierung immer
wieder geärgert zum beispiel mit seinem
kampf für das recht auf abtreibung aus
warschau natalie steger
wir bedanken uns rufen seine anhänger
ihm zu als adam bottner das polnische
verfassungsgericht verlässt das hat
entschieden der ombudsmann für
menschenrechte und kritiker der
polnischen regierung
sein amt aufgeben das urteil kann dem
gesetzgeber den raum blicken das im büro
des ombudsmanns so etwas wie ein
kommissarischer leiter eingesetzt wird
und nicht einen menschenrechts
beauftragten us amtszeit ist eigentlich
vorbei
aber weil sich regierung und opposition
nicht auf einen nachfolger einigen
konnten blieb er so sei es eine
bisherige regelung vor nicht
verfassungskonform
so nun das urteil des gerichts fest in
peace hand wenn uns der ombudsman fehlt
dann wird der start der bereits in
seinen grundfesten erschüttert ist
riesige probleme über große macht hat
der menschenrechtsbeauftragte nicht aber
er kann stören dass abbott nahm mehrfach
den umbau der justiz hatte kritisiert
die medienpolitik die in kritischen kurs
der staatsspitze gegenüber homosexuellen
und die verschärfung des
abtreibungsrechts allesamt
lieblingsprojekte der pis nun muss bot
nagel
die menschenrechtskommissarin des
europarats per twitter das urteil
schaffe eine besorgniserregende lücke
für die funktion des beauftragten und
den menschenrechtsschutz in polen mit
adam bodnar werden die
nationalkonservativen den chef einer der
letzten institutionen los die sie noch
nicht kontrollieren
die pis beweist erneut was nicht passt
wird passend gemacht
genau in diesen minuten heute vor zwei
jahren fraß sich ein feuer durch notre
dame vor den augen einer gestoppten welt
drohte das gotische meisterwerk
vollständig in schutt und asche zu
fallen
zum jahrestag hat präsident micronas
wahrzeichen im herzen von paris besucht
und sein versprechen erneuert notre dame
innerhalb von fünf jahren originalgetreu
wieder aufzubauen
aus jahrhunderte alten eichen
traditionshandwerk und mit 800 millionen
euro spendengeldern ja keinen spaß macht
der blick auf die champions league 3 ist
jetzt auch der letzte deutsche verein
haus ja erst die bayern und dann der bvb
dabei hatten die borussen gestern abend
in dortmund gegen manchester city
wie schon im knapp verlorenen hinspiel
eine richtig starke leistung gezeigt
aber es reichte wieder nicht
wieder gewann mancity mit 2 zu 1 m brett
scheinbar wie schon im hinspiel der
pechvogel der dortmunder nach der frühen
führung durch den erst 17-jährigen juke
bellingham die das halbfinale bedeutete
hätte kippte die partie gegen die
momentan vielleicht beste mannschaft der
welt zu beginn der zweiten halbzeit
dieses handspiel von chan ahndete der
schiedsrichter mit einem umstrittenen
aber vertretbaren strafstoß der
ausgleich durch maris verdarb den
dortmundern von vereinsboss watzke
erhoffte sensation mit guardiola
citizens setzte sich am ende die
spielstärkere mannschaft durch durch den
siegtreffer in der 75 minute
das ändert nichts daran dass wir uns
damit beschäftigen werden wieder zu
kräften zu kommen und dann am sonntag
eine ähnliche leistung zu zeigen damit
wir darum kämpfen nächstes jahr wieder
die möglichkeit haben solche spiele zu
bekommen
das dürfte ihnen die schwierig werden
wie für sie die das halbfinale gegen
paris st germain und ausgeschieden ist
auch der fc liverpool das team von
jürgen klopp kam im rückspiel gegen real
madrid nicht über ein torloses
unentschieden hinaus
diesmal half keine motivation kunst der
ball wollte einfach nicht rein glücklos
vor allem top-stürmer sosalla wir wissen
alle wie oft muss man solche dinge mit
geschlossenen augen verwandelt aber
nicht gestern mit dem 0 0 zu hause raus
aus dem europäischen geschäft liverpool
muss sich in der liga steigern um
nächste saison überhaupt dabei zu sein
ja und so sehen die halbfinal paarungen
aus real madrid spielt gegen fc chelsea
und paris gegen manchester city wegen
kroner müssen bei der abstiegsbedrohten
härter neben coach pal dardai auch die
beiden co trainer und stürmer dodi
lukaku in quarantäne
trotzdem soll stand jetzt das spiel der
berliner am sonntag gegen mainz
stattfinden
ja und jetzt noch ein spektakulärer last
second sieg im basketball
luna luca den chips von den dallas
mavericks wird den ball mit der
schlusssirene in den korb obwohl
von zwei gegnern in die zange genommen
wird und diese drei punkte bedeuteten
den sieg gegen die memphis grizzlies 114
113 der im stand toller wurf das war's
von swatch dankeschön bitte und zum
schluss noch etwas berührendes das welt
pressefoto des jahres im zeichen von
corona es heißt die erste umarmung fünf
monate lang war die 85 jährige rosa
lucia luna aus brasilien separiert in
einem rein als ihre pflegerin sie nach
dieser zeit um arm durch einen
speziellen vorhang zum schutz wirkt sie
so die jury wie ein engel
für den fotografen maz müssen eine
geschichte von hoffnung und liebe in den
schwierigsten zeiten auf nun liebe da
ist das wetter fast egal die nacht
bringt schnee und viele wollten mehr
dazu hat gleich als den termin um
viertel nach zehn freut sich marietta
slomka im heute journal auf sie und wir
freuen uns wenn sie morgen wieder dabei
sind
ich wünsche ihnen einen richtig schönen
abend auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter die strömung hat
sich etwas verändert und kommt
allmählich aus östlichen richtungen man
sieht hier schon hier ist schon die
bewölkung die allmählich reinzieht und
diese stimmung verdrängt allmählich die
kaltluft hier in streuselkuchen artiger
form und dementsprechend gibt es weniger
schauer aber viele wolken und etwas
regen und schnee vor allem im erzgebirge
und richtung vogtland in der kommenden
nacht im nordwesten da wird es
auflockern und sogar stern klar sein die
temperaturen sinken dazu auf minus fünf
grad an den alpen und drei grad an der
nordsee das ist die temperaturspanne
morgen vor allem im nordwesten viel
sonnenschein auch bis ins emsland und an
den rhein ansonsten im osten dichter
bewölkt mit etwas regen richtung
erzgebirge und vogtland gibt es etwas
schnee dazu ja unterrichtung meinen
regen an den alpen scheint häufiger die
sonne und das bei temperaturen von vier
bis zwölf grad und die nächsten tage am
samstag gibt es von osten her noch regen
und schneefälle wird es nicht sein bei 4
bis 13 grad oder am sonntag schoss genau
so wie am montag montag sogar bis 16
grad
ein schöner abend